so it appears the next step in the hunt
for the sleeper simulant has finally
arrived assuming you have collected all
four of the Dark Age relic fusion rifles
and turn them into banshee you should
have a new quest on earth called the
first firewall once you've arrived into
the mission head down to Rasputin's area
and get to this console once you get to
this console it's going to trigger an
event where nights and taking nights
spawn in a line try your best to take
down the order in which they spawn
because it's going to help with the
puzzle afterwards or you can just cheat
and continue watching the video as i'm
going to give you all the answers for
waves will spawn then a larger night
called the can direct will spawn go
ahead and dispatch up Kendrick as fast
as you can and you will receive a
curious transceiver here's the first
puzzle you're going to have to deal with
there's two rows that you're going to
need to fill out either top or bottom
which will mirror the sequences that the
Knights spawned in here are the answers
to all four sequences here's the first
sequence the second sequence the third
sequence and finally the fourth sequence
after you solved all the sequences
you're going to get a new quest called
shadow call once you've arrived into the
area and cross the bridge you're going
to notice that it's actually a timed
emission so go ahead and run by all the
taken until you get to this lift once
you've taken the lift up you're going to
open this chest which will then trigger
an event three Wizards are gonna spawn
that you're gonna have to kill with
whatever remaining time you have left
once you've killed all three Wizards
you're going to receive an item called
the e kilos fusion core here we're going
to start a second puzzle where you're
going to have to do five different tasks
three of the five tasks you're going to
need to do our war SAP patrols on Mars
the Moon and Earth and the final two
things you're going to need to do
require you to dismantle a heavy
legendary or exotic item and beat the
archive mission on Venus a cool thing to
note is that it doesn't matter what
difficulty you beat the archive mission
once you have unlocked and repaired the
fusion core take it back to Banshee and
he'll tell you he needs more time to
check it out so it appears we're going
to have to wait a little bit longer to
get our hands on the sleeper simulant
another thing to note before we end this
video is bungee has come out and said
that this is a limited-time event you're
definitely going to want to do it today
if you've collected all four of your
Dark Age relic items however if you
haven't gotten them yet just try your
best to get them they are random drops
once you get one make sure to turn it
into banshee as you can only hold one at
a time this is another situation like
the black spindle where it seems like
it's kind of on a specific day we don't
know when it's going to come back maybe
it's going to be in a couple of days
maybe a few weeks maybe a month who
knows if you can somehow find a way to
farm all four if you haven't gotten them
yet do so today and do the mission as
soon as you can stay tuned and gamespot
com for more continuing coverage of
destiny the taken King
you